Marc Spears senior NBA rider from ESPN
affirm undefeated here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you mark I am great so walk
me through the conversation you had with
David West in Cleveland I'm in this
locker room and it's like soaked with
champagne I'm like like literally like
puddles and I think David had a few cups
glasses so to speak
the only time I've really seen him very
animated is when they won last year and
this year so and so he you know kind of
just said himself was kind of
unsolicited that a man there was a lot
of stuff going on the scenes and if you
if you knew boy would blow your mind
you'd be shocked to know what was going
on behind the scenes I'm like okay what
was it can't tell you can't tell you but
when it comes out Wow so now I actually
went to talk to Shaun Livingston and
then David West sticks his head outside
the training room and started screaming
to him I know he's going to try to find
out I know he's trying to ask you about
it but that's where I got the quote
about you know her from Sean lemon Stan
and then draymond said that the team
definitely went through a lot of s you
know what I mean
and so there was something going on they
wouldn't give in to it but what I heard
is there was at least two players who
had some real personal things going on
this season that that affected the team
along the way personal things you mean
in their personal lives that might have
affected their business relationship
yeah you know things that they were
dealing with that you know cuz they're
they're close-knit family so it's
inevitable if you work with somebody and
they're going through some stuff it it
trickles down to you as well because you
see him every day
um Sean Levinson told me when asked
about he said you know we we keep our
business clothes we don't have air it
out to the outside media so so I guess
there but but but there's something I
know so then what to make of it because
if it's something that's so crazy that
everybody's telling you it's crazy what
we dealt with yeah and and
they dealt with it and they won it all
and so what what should it matter right
I wonder if it you know I wonder how
much of it was real that how much of it
was the alcohol you know like but
usually when someone says that while
they drinking there's some truth to it
right so I don't know it's intriguing
it's kind of weird thing to get tossed
out when they won the championship and
I've been trying to figure it out and
show a lot of media have been trying to
figure it out but I don't know exactly
what he meant so as of right now Marc
Spears from the undefeated here on the
Rich Eisen show I gotta be I mean I'm
trying to interpret what you're saying
here Marc and you know I've been around
a lot of locker rooms and I don't know
if it involves significant others that
everybody was involved in I think that
that's the sort of crazy s yeah that
that I'm kind of picking up am I am i
warm I don't want that you know I don't
know what it is I mean with you would
you what you think so
when you think of crazy s shoot it could
be anything
I'm as intrigued as you and but perhaps
after this was said I think behind the
scenes I'm glad like everybody I've
asked about it kind of gaming this look
of acknowledgment but won't say a thing
so okay I guess to beat just you'd be
figured out I guess later so what you
have more for you on it man no no it's
all good but that one just it jumped out
at me and I played in the previous
segment Marcus soundbite of the exchange
between mark Schwartz and and Kevin
Durant where Durant just tamp down
immediately any conversation of
potential jealousy over who wins the MVP
of the NBA Finals or not and then you
know obviously conversations like this
sports fans who are sitting there in
Oakland wanting to just celebrate three
and four here this sort of thing and
think that we're we're trying to poke
holes in it at all but to me that's the
story is how long can this last
right I mean that's the issue
moving forward because what else we
gonna talk about until somebody can put
together a team that can beat mark well
after the game was over with I saw Steph
Curry walking in the hallway and with a
cigar and somebody mentioned Durant
winning MVP and if he cared about it and
like I'm a champ so you know so I don't
think curry cares
he's about winning championships he
actually said in a text message to
Durant and when they were trying to
recruit them hey if you win MVP I'll be
right there cheering for you you know so
I mean is it something that's missing
out of Stephon Curry's big collection of
things that includes championship
trophies and gold medals and such and
MVP trophies from the regular season yes
but in the grand scheme of things I
think he's more worried about that
championship and then that Finals
Hardware so then what's the next step
here for the Warriors mark obviously
Durant's already told Rachel Nichols
that he plans to stay put so what what's
next for them well you know I think
they're gonna try to get clay and dream
on to sign extensions I expect the core
to stay intact I see them perhaps going
to some of their youth patrocle mclaurel
probably will have a bigger role keeping
hot and I owned a man Jones I know a lot
of people don't know him but I think
he'll probably end up being a
replacement for JaVale McGee he's as
athletic just as good blocks shot
blocker he reminds me actually a Clint
capela just just a real stable young
player who just got caught up in the
numbers and didn't play
Kevon Looney is a restricted free agent
although I think that I'll get shot up
bringing him back so you know Clinton
cook will be back so obviously
Livingston and Iguodala will be coming
off the bench so they'll add they want
to try to add some youth but they
already have some youth under on a
roster on a bench so I think they're
gonna give more of a chance to next
season so I thinking and then the next
question I guess mark is the biggest
threats to the Warriors from outside the
building and that would matter LeBron
that's there
yeah and so my question for you is what
do you think is the biggest threat
LeBron teaming up with somebody or the
Celtics what do you think mark uh I
think Boston's gonna be amazing rich I
saw them in the preseason for Gordon
Hayward got hurt I actually picked them
to plate of warriors in the finals of
Florida season started and when I saw
him playing Charlotte they were
absolutely amazing together
I mean Tatum's gonna be better I mean
they they were like warriors east
extremely fun to watch they weren't like
the team that played the Cavs in these
finals this team could score they hit a
lot of threes ran Kyrie was amazing with
this group yeah so wherever LeBron goes
I mean if he goes in the West he still
has to get through the warrior so I do
think the Celtics are the biggest threat
right now so then where do you think
LeBron goes mark I know that's the
that's the million or the you know the
manege million keep an eye on that
nobody's talking about go for it
what is Chris Paul gonna do because I
think that's key they are close they are
really really close that's why his days
of playing what weight are done right
for LeBron playing with Melo over a
possible you know but Chris Paul and him
very close I could see them joining
together with the Lakers I don't know
anything I just wonder what you know
what is Chris gonna do could he is it
more attractive to return to Houston and
finish it or could it be attractive to
finally be in a Lakers uniform with
LeBron James he you know Chris still
lives in LA in all season I think
there's a lot for him to think about so
to me he he has the key to this whole
thing that perhaps a lot of people are
not talking about so you think the first
conversation after LeBron checks in with
his family will be with Chris Paul he
picks up the phone I want to be
surprised they spoken already I can't
see the Chris Mullin Cleveland though so
what if I was Houston I'd certainly be
concerned
how about that where's Kauai in this
whole thing you know I
seems like San Antonio is gonna let the
dust settle and keep them I wonder how
the fans will feel about it I wonder how
his teammates will feel about it they
certainly didn't seem to miss him in the
playoffs they certainly were appeared
perturbed by them and I could understand
I mean not even being there to support
them I'm not you know during the
playoffs not even being on a bench I
don't buy that he would have been a
distraction thing you know so I think
there's a lot of kissing up to do and
hugging um for it to work out but he's
just too talented not to I mean unless
they're trade them for LeBron James I
can't see him going anywhere what about
LeBron going there playing for pop what
do you tell you know what I think
remember in 2010 when you know the
decision before the decisions but there
was a lot of meetings in downtown
Cleveland for LeBron where he spoke to I
remember he spoke to the Clippers it
seemed like he spoke to everybody I
wouldn't be surprised if such takes
place again where there's a opportunity
for a lot of different people to give a
sales pitch and I know he's a big fan of
Popovich um they're really really close
but um man he certainly has a lot to
choose from
and I'll bet you there will be at least
10 suitors wanting to knock on that door
and see what he I mean it's also
intriguing that Toronto has a higher to
coach are they waiting to see if he'd be
interested so he could hire a coach he
wants you know it's just I think there's
about 10 horses in this race and right
now if I was a betting man I'd take the
Lakers as the front-runner
in the minute I have with you left Marc
Dwane Casey signed with the Pistons just
as we were going on the air what do you
think of that fit uh
I saw him over the weekend at the finals
he seemed like he was close to making
that decision go there they don't have a
lot of cap home I talked to him about
that
to really do anything but if you look at
the end of the Pistons regular season
I believe they won like seven other last
ten games
when they were healthy so if this team's
healthy they're a playoff team how far
they go I don't know is there's not much
they could do in free agency but I think
Blake Griffin will certainly nin
Drummond will certainly do well on the
case great job this season mark let's
chat over the next few weeks prior to
the draft and and after Dwane Casey
picks up the coach of the Year award the
piston defendant first time with the
Raptors I hope you get the boat is from
that maybe he will thanks thanks for the
call mark all right brother you got at
mark with a CJ Spears ESPN the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience